[Music]
hello there
it's update day in fortnight which means
new changes to the map
and the progression of this season's
story there are actually two key
storylines happening alongside each
other right now so if you like a little
law
this video is for you so sit your butt
down for five minutes slap code adamaru
in the store to support this
long-running series
and let's break down fortnite chapter
two season six
week seven let's go
first an update for those people reading
the batman fortnite zero point comic
book series
in issue two coming next week batman
will construct
the bat shed and we know that because
it's here in fortnite
today down in slurpy swamps sits the
caped crusader's first attempt at a bat
cave in fortnite
it's not up to his usual standard but it
sure is functional i guess
batman has placed his logo over the door
to remind himself to visit here
as like other characters in game he lost
his memory
inside there is more evidence of the bat
his batarangs are on the desk there's
books to read for weeks
and he's built up an addiction to slurp
juice can't blame him for that
the main focus seems to be this
chalkboard batman is writing notes and
theories about the loop
as he attempts to get back to gotham the
concept of 22-minute loops will be next
on his agenda
and relating to that check above the
door a fully functioning clock
i was impressed by that batsy has
erected a small satellite dish on top of
the budget batcave
and i for one can't wait for the next
comic issue to drop
if you're not keeping up with the comic
books or need a refresher i've started a
recap series with things you need to
know i'll link it for those who want to
stay updated
before we go another huge piece of law
we discovered today was that batman
has a favorite bedtime teddy on the
island a purple
llamacorn even huge rugged manly men
need snuggies sometimes
let's see where this story takes us next
week
okay the next update is so random i have
no idea
what to call it in a similar spot to the
btec bat cave
just below flush factory is this a new
steaming micro island
i'm going to call it turd island to see
if we can get that into law
it works for kevin the cube and hut
watch you never know turd island may
catch on
okay seriously this already has a name
it's called oral isle
relating to the character oro so it
looks like we're going to get some lore
next time around
about the king of gold and maybe that
will lead to midas
and his daughters this could be a core
story or it could be like the last time
an island like this popped up
where we met the coral critters the good
old wobbly blobs if it's the main story
or a side story either way
we're getting some law very soon let's
check back up on turd island i mean oral
isle next time oh let's just get this
out the way
[Music]
as expected the sheriff location is
indeed over and done with
so this part of hot watch will not be
revisited hang on hang on
there is an update the sheriff has
rounded up more
of the gnome population maybe this story
is not over just yet
i feel a jailbreak is coming on
imminently i'll keep an eye on it thanks
for reminding me to come back
i guess hot watch is forever i mean but
once forever
[Music]
so mr neymar jr joined fortnite he's a
football legend who spends more time on
his back
than nope not a mum joke today i have
matured
around the island are football pitches
soccer fields if you prefer
with npcs to talk to and a big old goal
to smash shops into
i think these are pretty
self-explanatory so we'll move on
my favorite one is at the docks i
believe that's it for location updates
so let's move on to the law
over the last six weeks we've come to
learn about the island and the
corruption spreading due to the spire
and always remember that big boy rock
the dwayne johnson is still in there
being all foundationy we picked up a
mysterious audio log in week three
telling us to listen to the crystal song
and then we followed that up in week
five with this device
which told us to talk to jonesy clones
then we had to prove our worth by
defeating johnsy the first
and he joined us now to this week raz
has become a ghostly mess
after collecting aspire artifact the
thing is
he's now split into two personalities
two people
the chap we speak to at the old coliseum
and now he's also a guardian
at the spire in his new corrupted form
by speaking to the other characters we
build up a little more law artifact
hunter lara croft warned raz against
searching for spire artifacts
and that much power is bound to attract
attention
hinting that something is coming for the
power he now holds
razzy's sister is a little bit more to
the point saying well
i've always known raz was an idiot but
it turns out
he's also a fool nothing good comes from
the spire
stay away we are then sent to face the
corrupted raz in an attempt to defeat
him
the thing is he has unreal powers now
like the shade step the other guardians
use
but raz has something new an ability to
steal
life energy from anyone who ventures too
close
of course i tested out to see if i could
be eliminated
and yeah yeah totally deaded here's the
best bit though
upon defeating raz and reducing him to
ashes we receive his bow which rotates
through all the other bows in the game
right now that's no big deal for me
but this is the spire artifact
a crystal of pure power sitting for us
to collect
upon closer inspection we can see that
this has the exact same runes as those
we see on kevin the
cube the rebirth of the sacred cube is
closer every week
now we have the power of the spire and
the support of jonesy the first
week nine is gonna be epic so how did i
do this week
if i missed anything please let me know
in the comments and i'll add it next
time i'll leave you with another bunch
of legends who were kind enough to use
my code adamarrow in the store last week
thank you very much really appreciated
i'll be back with more fortnite content
as soon as issue 2 of batman fortnite
zero point drops
it's been a pleasure see ya